welcome my name is duane hendricks
titleist access
um
i usually hang out
in detroit
i moved there four years ago but i'll
get into that
um
i wanted to acknowledge that i've spoken
to w380 twice before
the first time was sometime during the
90s i don't remember exactly when
i don't remember i couldn't find my
slide deck for
for then but i i remember it
in my mind's eye i remember the dinner i
was taken to after the talk
so hey
um but the last time i spoke to
this colloquium was
may
okay
and
um
the talk was networking tonga from the
ground up in the sky down
okay
so at the time i was doing this big
project in the kingdom of tonga in the
south pacific
so
14 years basically have passed since i
addressed this august body
so
um i've been basically known
i'm a serial entrepreneur and i've done
a lot of things in my career but i've
been sort of tagged as the wireless guy
okay
so i wanted to sort of bring this up
right at the front because
uh
i do a lot more than just wireless okay
so as you'll find out so
um
native of detroit
i left detroit in 1970 to go to southern
illinois university carbondale
to work with bucky fuller and what was
new at the time
the world game
so i met fuller
and worked with him
in his design department there
um why was this iu the arpanet was
coming into play and
siu had a connection to the arpanet via
the university of illinois
so we had this uh
tty that was connected to u of i
and we could do this play with this
arpanet thing and at the time i have to
i didn't know what the hell it was about
all right but it was there and it was
free
um
i left
siu in
76 and came here to the valley to work
for amdahl corporation
okay so that gets into i've done a lot
of things i came to amdahl to be a vm
370 systems programmer
okay
um i stopped working for other people
in 1980
and since 1980 i've been doing my own
companies either as a
founder co-founder
ceo
vp whatever was appropriate
i've done six
one of which has gone public
that was tetherless access limited went
public in
96 on nasdaq
and disappeared two years after that
was ahead of its time
um
but that was the wireless internet
startup that i co-founded with a guy
named charlie brown in 1990. so think
about 1990
we were basically trying to raise money
for doing metropolitan area wireless
internet
okay needless to say
there wasn't a lot of
scratch for that at the time we didn't
get funded until
94.
we got a million and a half bucks from
uh
hedge fund in san francisco
okay so
in a way we went so we deployed a lot of
wireless networks in a lot of developing
countries that was our forte because to
be honest
there wasn't any action here in the
united states
where in developing countries it was
like we need infrastructure we want the
internet okay and we want to do stuff
and and so the money flowed
in 96 i was a member of a national
science foundation funded project to
bring the internet to mongolia
and i bring this up because i think it's
important because
you don't bring the internet to a
country
for the first time that often
and uh nsf funded a satellite ground
station which had the speed of 256
kilobits symmetric
okay
and my role was to
distribute
this was the capital of mongolia ulan
batar
and distributed from the satellite
ground station all over the city and
create a
wireless man
okay
so the state department was involved
and we were able to ship all our
equipment over to
mongolia via the
diplomatic pouch
so and we staged
our entry into mongolia through china so
we ended up in beijing so i could go on
i could tell tales about that particular
trip those of you who know glenn tenney
of the hackers conference glenn and i
were the team that went there and
actually was in mongolia the pi for that
project was dave hughes
known as the cursor cowboy john
well the way it works is that you just
give them stuff
at whatever the size and then they
figure out how to get it there and they
don't exactly tell you when it's going
to get there you just turn it over and
it appears
my friend tom
the first email from the south pole and
he has a photo
with his with his dish it'll fit in
basically um a case that you could put
in an overhead bin
um
because i know you john if you want to
copy that picture now this one i'll get
tom to get a photo to you sorry about
that no problem
but
one other aspect of this thing is that
we hit it was like planning safari to
darkest africa
and we had that there was no radio shack
you could go to
so we had to bring everything you know
we needed to to do this
and uh that was a real challenge and uh
we had asked the locals to do a site
survey and when we found got there we
found out that there were all these
russian concrete buildings surrounding
the base station that were higher than
the base station
okay
and
um
we thought that was it it was time to go
home well we decided to do
an experiment
okay so we decided to deploy
the 900 megahertz data radios spread
spectrum data radios we were using
and it turned out that there was a quirk
in the construction of these buildings
so that they were transparent at 900
megahertz
okay
so uh
yeah i mean so we were able to punch
through with you know uh a lot of power
and cover what we needed to cover in the
city
so this is an important lesson here is
that you know
experimentation works in that never say
die what all the other things phrases
you can think of but
try it maybe it'll work okay and it did
all right
uh as the basis as a result of all that
i got dub
bought to be the broadband cowboy by
wired magazine in 2002 they did this
profile and
you know well you got some of you wired
they make stuff up and it's like how did
i get to be the broadband cowboy because
you see any boots you know hat no
okay
but i think what they were trying to go
for was this sort of
doing
things off the grid or you know not
normal being innovative and whatever so
okay
so
i want to call out two of my
primary mentors in my career bucky
fuller
and paul barron now bucky i actually did
a startup
in uh carmendale
and it was a communication startup
and communications networking startup
and bucky was an investor
and he put money into it for about a
year
okay
it never went anywhere because it was
another one of these head of his time
things but he was an investor and he did
that and that's a little known as becca
bucky he'd do lectures and then the
money he got he would
do
venture capital
okay
and then paul barron
paul was i think the epitome for serial
entrepreneurs
uh you guys know paul metrocom
com21 all kinds of stuff
so um
paul was a ham
i'm a ham radio operator
and that's how i met paul through that
fellowship of amateur radio
so i moved back to detroit in 2010 okay
because you've all heard the detroit
stories and as a native i wanted to go
back there and see what i could do to
try to turn things around
and here it is a number of years later
and nope
there's nothing i can do
so i want to talk a little bit about the
title
on the framing there
um
i
have been working on a project with the
henry ford museum
in
greenfield village in dearborn michigan
for a number of years now and it's
related to the maker faire
and the whole maker movement
and
i've been applying james burke's
connection
methodology
to taking the collection at the henry
ford
and sort of going and saying look this
thing in the collection
was relates to this which relates to
that and is connected to this and
connected to that and bring it into the
the current time with maker projects
okay so i have a site that's called we
are all makers so the idea is trying to
show
makers today
that there are lessons from the past
that can help them do a better job as to
what they're doing okay so for instance
one of the things
at the henry ford is the
thomas edison's
menlo park laboratory
which is where he did the first
commercial lighting system not the first
light bulb
but the first commercial lighting system
okay
and that's they're reproduced and
there's a power plant there dc power
that powers the street lights
so
and but it was the first industrial
laboratory in the united states and you
get a chance to see
how that was put together
and the accounting functions the
publicity it was an engine to uh do
science
or make money
okay pure and simple
and so i've i've been able to take all
that and
and and give some talks and stuff about
how that's done and how it relates to a
lot of the maker projects where they
don't look to for instance the money
angle
so it's just sort of a short-term game
kind of thing okay
but
when i started to put together this talk
i basically looked to the 19th century
and what happened there in terms of
looking for
early internet
and
i'm working with a colleague and friend
mike leapold at the institute for the
future in palo alto
and
we're working on a project which we're
calling we started calling plan b
internet
and we're now sort of calling it second
curve internet and we'll probably end up
calling it something else but
um
mike came up with a framing and
narrative
that
was i think much more powerful than me
being stuck in the 19th century and that
he took it all the way back to greek
mythology okay
and that
think about it it's like
the internet can be found back there
okay
at least some aspects of it and i'll
show you this because it's sort of
fascinating because i think it sort of
speaks to
when you say this word the internet what
does it mean
you know
okay so
and what i've discovered is that little
is really new when you look at it at a
certain level historically okay
and i'll try to show that
and so let us begin
so as part of this connections work i
sort of have a set of first principles
or premises
first comes the technology
as time passes it becomes more
accessible and affordable
good enough is acceptable for most folks
more than we know is always happening
under our radar screen
and finally
because one of my first loves is
wireless this thing wireless is like one
of the technologies that we have that's
sort of like magic
so i'm quoting clark's third law which
is any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
we all use wireless one from another but
few of us know how it works even experts
in the field don't really know how it
works
and i can assure you that okay
but that's a talk for another day
but
i'll get into the wireless angle because
wireless can be used to build
infrastructure and that relates to
where we might go with the internet
so
now i'm going to go back to the 19th
century
so prior to the 1830s
the fastest way you could communicate
was by horse or the fastest one driven
ship
okay
that all changed
in the 1830s with the
invention and deployment of the
telegraph
so all of a sudden the world went from
foot speed to light speed
now if you go back and look at the
historical documents in that period
it affected society globally
tremendously okay and since we don't go
back and do that we have no idea
but i've sort of done that
and there's a a good great book about
that and then
by guy named tom standish which i'll
have a slide in in a second but
if you read some of the historical
documents then
they sound like things that could have
been written
today
i have a bill
from the house
where the startup company is petitioning
the congress to
fund
a transcontinental telegraph system
that would be buried
not on polls but buried
okay
and if you read this proposal and how
it's being evaluated in committee and
all that stuff because i got i got the
whole bill and i want to put it up
online
so you can see it but it's a fascinating
document because you can read this thing
and just say
what this is 1854 you know
and you don't really get that until you
see him talking about
telegraph and how many words they can
send per second okay i mean per minute
okay and then you say oh that's a pretty
slow
physical layer okay
but all the other politics and the
funding and the you know it's all like
today okay
so
remember i said that when the textuality
comes out
that
it's not that accessible
well the gateway to the telegraph system
were these guys
you go to a telegraph office you give
them some money and they send the
message
so i call out this book by tom standage
of the victorian internet
it's a quick read but it really gives
you a sense of the parallels between
what we're facing now and have faced and
will face
and what they went through in the 19th
century
now the timeline was pretty long then
because it took a long time to deploy
the telegraph you know
and then the reason that the startup
that i mentioned didn't get their
funding was this thing called the civil
war intervened and everything just that
kind of stuff stopped dead
all right
but think about it i mean to bury a
telegraph line
all the way across the country
okay and there were technical reasons
why that thought would that was a better
reproach like approach like it was more
resilient
you know because they had seen what
happened to you know with weather
okay so it think about it if that he got
funded the first fiber system
all right
but it did
so after the civil war they laid the
transcontinental cable to bring
telegraphy across the atlantic
and then later in the 19th century this
thing called the telephone came about
and
i don't cover the telephone because i
just want to stick with this telegraphy
thing but i do want to call it telephony
to the extent that the telephone network
if the telegraph network was that you go
to some place and you give them money
and they send a message okay so that was
the access metaphor all right
telephone of course got installed in
your home
all right so that was really different
all right but
i want to put that aside
so if we look at telegraphic networking
if you look at the access issues i
covered the infrastructure
well you had a lot of different
telegraph companies
okay
independent
lots of them but to send messages across
the country or some
distance they had to interconnect the
networks
so they developed a networking protocol
suite
okay
to do internet working
all right
um
and there were costs associated with
that all right so all that got worked
out our government got involved and the
thing is we are really
ignorant about how that process worked
now historians like standards go back
and look at it and they say wow you know
this is really like the kind of stuff
we're hearing in the news today about
the internet and peering and yada yada
yada okay
lessons learned
so
let's go to marconi
things change
so remember my first principle
as the technology evolves it becomes
more accessible and more affordable
all right
so
with
telegraphy and the telephone
you have wires physical wires that you
lay
and there's a cost
associated with that
wireless change the game
okay because now you could have path
between point a and point b that was
completely arbitrary
and different business models developed
so from the time
marconi sent the first signal across the
atlantic in 1901
he started there where there were
commercial wireless services in 1903 so
what you're seeing is a compressed
timeline
okay
from what you saw with telegraphy over
the span of the 19th century
but here's the deal
if you want to send it a message over
wireless you still had to go to this
office now you might be able to do it
from a hotel where you fill out a form
and they take it to the office but there
was somebody always in the way you
didn't have access to the network
you as an individual
and guess what
there was no transition in that
you know this stuff propagate wireless
propagated light speed telegraphy so it
was light speed to light speed so there
wasn't any real major change
to the system
except in some very subtle ways like the
telephone
a network access device in your home
that changed things
okay
but
as we moved into broadcasting after the
titanic
sink okay
and now you could go to a store
and buy a network access device called a
radio
okay you put in your home and now you
have access to this networking thing
so telephone's two-way broadcasting
isn't
and the general public didn't have
access to two-way
transmission
until
you know
fairly recently like wi-fi
unlicensed spectrum unlicensed devices
that's when
we got
parody with the telephone system using
wireless technologies
that's very important so um
but the same thing again you had a lot
of independent companies doing wireless
um they had to have a network protocol
suite
and they did internetworking okay
because wireless
like only with a certain distance if you
look at the titanic disaster and how
that was handled there were a lot of
ships that relayed messages and so there
was a protocol okay packet
hopping
so
commercial inert comes in
about 95 i'm using 95 and we could
quibble about four you know plus or
minus one
but
this was a big difference for us
because we went from what i call
light speed to warp speed
okay
faster than light and i say that because
of the network effect medcast law reads
law
okay
mesh
so you had a different kind of
architecture for this internet working
thingy than we had with other
technologies in the past
so
um
i don't i mean we all know about this
slide i mean we could uh
talk about it at length but
let me move to
here
the internet
so to coin a phrase from the princess
bride
you keep using that word i don't think
it means what you think it means
and that is sort of the crux of where we
are today in that
if you look at my background i've been
doing internet working
for a long time
in a lot of different places
okay
and
i've been able to
use the end-to-end principle to do
peer-to-peer to do mesh networking all
that stuff because i was using wireless
so i could create infrastructure like
this
and a lot of other people like me right
now in the united states there's about
four
thousand wireless isps
okay but you would know it because of
what
well a lot of things the media
but
uh this internet thing there's remember
i mentioned the icarus thing in
mythology
there's a famous line from the movie the
man who shot liberty and balance
from the end
when the legend becomes the truth
print the legend
okay
so a corollary would be when the myth
becomes the truth
print the myth
okay and that's sort of what we got
okay this internet has become this
mythical thing
that has meaning to
different meanings to whoever you know
politicians have a meaning like it's the
tubes
and we can have fun with that all day
um
let me tell you what it means to me
you know early on
when i was trying to do a startup and
make money okay
it
the internet to me was
independently owned and operated
networks
that communicate with each other using
this common protocol suite this tcp
protocol suite
okay
so
we run our networks
we spend the money to keep the
infrastructure up and running
and we agree to peer and that's how we
move packets
that was what the internet
has been for me for a long time
okay
that's not what the internet is for a
lot of people today
okay
all right
if you go back a few years ago
to the fcc under um when obama came in
and brought in janikowski and they
started the national broadband plan
okay if you read that national broadband
plan i think the internet is maybe
mentioned once but it's all it's
broadband it's broadband access
broadband access right but
access to what and why
that's not really covered
so
it's glaring a mission
but it's also symptomatic of the problem
we have today okay because you got this
net neutrality thing and um
okay so
here
i subscribe to the rachel maddow shows
newsletter okay so for the last week
there's been this ad from the motley
crew embedded
in
her newsletter
you know which basically says rest in
peace internet 1969-2014
okay
it's been running every day for about a
week
and so when i was putting this talk
together i looked at that and says wow
you know
there's there's something going on here
okay
and
and then
yesterday
i saw an article in a pretty prominent
online tech pub
that was called titled the internet is
and it used a lot of harsh language
but that was a subject line and
it was designed to get your attention
obviously okay
but it went down all the different
things that we sort of have heard about
net neutrality
uh the post stone world we're in privacy
all that stuff it was a pretty long
article
hit all the points
and
seemed to adopt the position that hey
you know we can fix this
okay
so
i told you what my id of what the
internet it's operational definition for
me you know i can go up and build a
network
using wireless
i can connect it to other wireless
networks like i said there's four
thousand wireless isps there are a
number of operating in the bay area i
had a friend asked me today
gee um
how would i get the internet where i am
in cupertino you know i said well you
know besides going to comcast i said
well there's probably a wireless isp
that covers you but most of the wireless
isps have gotten out of the residential
access market
because there's no money there
you know
14 years ago i was a wireless isp
trying to slug it out here in the bay
area
i had a mountaintop site on
mount allison and milpitas
and
i was broadcasting there in fact
in 98 when i was working for com21
i had a system
up there
that used the cable modem system that
com21 created i turned it into a
wireless cable system
and i had coverage from los gatos all
the way up to san mateo
okay
and at the time i think our modems did
uh
15 down and two up
okay
so this is 98.99
and what we did is we just sprinkle them
around to different people in the bay
area you know our friends and said hey
use this thing
it gives you high-speed connection to
the internet and all we require you to
do is talk to people about it
okay
so
what
i want to do with this talk
and leave you with
is sort of showing you what the realm of
possibilities are
because you've all been sort of in this
world where you know there's a lot of
constraints there you sort of have
forgotten what's possible
okay
because you don't put down wires you
wait for people to put down wires
because of all the various issues
associated with it
wireless is different now there are
problems with wireless but this is not
the place to go into that and in fact
i'm not here to go into any particular
protocol
okay because there are places to do that
what i want to try to do here is to get
you to remember
if you've forgotten or learned now
what the internet is the internet is an
abstract noun
okay
it's not a bunch of fiber or access
methods or whatever it's what you make
of it
and that the founding fathers the
internet gray bears created this
protocol suite
which allows you to enables
conversations
okay
and you can use it to set up any kind of
conversation you want pretty much
okay it's not perfect
but to use a phrase from the ietf
we believe in rough consensus and
running code
all right
so
now one of my close friends
david p reid
uh was one of the co-developers of the
yen to end principal
and
he's been fighting this battle for a
while now to try to get people to
remember what the internet's about so
last september he wrote this nice
blog post
you know which is titled what the
internet is and should continue to be
and he sets forth the fundamental you
know what i think principles or the
operational definition of what that is
so i encourage you to go and seek out
this
blog post paper by david
it's very short and very succinct
okay
but
i think it does
goes a long way to
helping us remember what the internet
was
and could be
now
i want to talk about what
this project i'm working with the
institute
is we're solid calling the second curve
internet in that we've got this first
curve and then you can apply this sort
of methodology back to the 19th century
and you look at how things progress over
time
uh there's some frightening fascinating
aspects of this but anyway so we're
looking at things that are coming on
early that may
allow this second curve internet to uh
bloom so remember i said that my first
principles that
there's a lot of stuff going on under
the radar screen that you're not aware
of so i think we can all sort of
relate to that
i certainly can
but
because you know things like all of a
sudden like there's this startup that
comes out of nowhere and is worth two
billion dollars you know and they you
know you hear this and they're doing
something and whatever it is is worth
two billion dollars
okay
but
you could look at where we are with the
internet
now
again
the
article the internet is
or the internet basically is going to
die this year and be set
you know rest in peace
so if you believe that well
what does that mean what are we going to
do
okay because comcast is still going to
be there
time warner's still going to be there
and their internet access providers
or their access providers to something
a silo of something you know walled
garden whatever you want but you know
it's like
when i travel
like starting about 2000
okay
you go to a hotel you get interactive
and i had all these
peer-to-peer apps
on my laptop okay and so i
get access to the internet or something
and i found a lot of my
apps didn't work because certain tcp
ports were blocked or ip ports for block
udp ports for block okay
and i just say okay
that's it for that right now until i get
back home
so i saw this you know a long time ago
and then
you know more recently people started
yelling and screaming about comcast is
blocking bittorrent or whatever and i
was like well
you know wake up net neutrality
left the barn
took a ship and went to europe you know
10 years ago
okay
in your fight you're worrying about it
now wake up but to be fair people
weren't running
the kind of apps
until more recently like a bittorrent
okay which attempts to do peer-to-peer
stuff
okay
there are two projects i want to
showcase in this part of the talk
um
the free network foundation
ebon moglin columbia university
um several years back
um
eben
and richard stallman
now stallman we could talk about
stallman for
but let's i'll just talk about evan
oglen and leave it at that all right
so evan's rational and uh lucid and
responsible so
um
and and based quite often
evan looked at where things were going
and he said look you know um
there's this intern internetworking
thing and
we've got to get internet working back
to the grassroots so we need to
basically
put servers in people's hands people
need to run servers
okay
and then
people went to evidence says wait a
minute you know you need to be a network
you're talking about running bgp
at the community level you know it's
like have grandma run a bgp
router
okay that's not going to work how is it
going to work
so
because that's what internet working is
like if you're part of uh you know the
uh network operators group is like you
got to run bgp that's you know put this
badge on i run bgp
okay i peer
that's your badge of entry
so
you can go to
the
free networking foundation's website but
what i want to hit or what i hope are
the salient points in that they put
together a development team to develop
the code open source open hardware
necessary to make this vision a reality
now it's a hard piece of work because
how do you take these
tcp protocol suite and sort of simplify
it or put something on top of it around
it
to make it accessible to grandma
okay
so
evan calls it innovation under austerity
uh
several years ago he gave a talk to
david eisenberg's freedom to connect
conference it's up on youtube in the
freedoms connect youtube channel
it's called innovation under austerity
it's about 90 minutes
and
those of us who were there
when he was done he just stood up and
just did this talk no notes just
extemporaneously gave this talk
and when he was done everybody jumped up
and gave him like a five minute standing
ovation
doc searles
said it was akin to martin luther's
king's i have a dream speech and i would
agree with that okay in terms of
the relevancy to this problem of what is
the internet and how do we solve the
problems that are sort of
getting it off track
innovation under austerity
okay because you're not going to get
money you're not going to get funding to
try to do this and so evan has a plan
and that plan is outlined in this talk
now
new american foundation and the beltway
they have a program called the open
technology institute which is run by
uh sasha meinrath
okay
and
they've been working for several years
on something called the commotion
project
they got money from the state department
okay to fund this
internet working system that you could
plop down in egypt amidst all the
turmoil and create a number of
independently operated
networks that would peer with each other
in exchange and have conversations
okay
that would deal with privacy concerns
encryption all that stuff all right so
that
your
garden
variety agitator could
set up a network
now there was uh some talk in certain
circles about well this is money from
the state department so where's the back
door
i mean come on there has to be a back
so you know
um but they just but this what commotion
does
it uses wireless technology to set up
infrastructure but it does something
that's sort of different than what we've
seen before
and that it uses the cellular system
okay
so inside this box is a open bts space
station
okay so it can do gsm where appropriate
so there are basically modules you can
plug and play to get the kinds of
physical layer stuff you need to set up
the network you want
commotion
well the state department's still
funding it
okay
now
even post-snowden okay
because a lot of what this is about is
improving your opsec operational
security so that
the nsa can't spy on you
okay
how many of you use pgp here
i was at a conference
last september
in woods hall
massachusetts and
it was sort of a
i wouldn't say undisclosed location but
it was there were 50 people there who
a lot of you would know
and
we were sort of there to discuss the
future of the of the net
uh a lot of internet graveyards were
there at this event so um
and bruce schneier the security expert
was there
um
and he was fresh from seeing all the
snowden documents
so what we had a chance to see
was him preparing stories to be printed
in the guardian but also talking at
great length about
uh what was going on with the stone
documents and all that stuff
and one of the discussions we had
with the people there was that
we all needed to improve our opsec
because what bruce said was
that
the intelligence agencies
um if you encrypt
then basically
you're okay with a lot of the bulk
surveillance
okay but if for targeted surveillance
when they decide to go after you they're
gonna get you
okay
so um i found out that bruce at the time
uh
and he was pretty open and honest about
this when he started to try to get
access to the stone document his opsec
wasn't up the snuff
okay and they said no no no you need to
improve
okay
and i found out that
bruce um
wasn't using pgp
okay and if you go to the public key
server and pull down bruce schneier's
public key
you'll see that it was first created in
september of last year
okay
now i i mentioned this not to dig at
bruce but just to show you that hey you
know even a security expert
doesn't necessarily get it right all the
time okay
now what we found and we we had a pgp
key signing party
so a lot of people there
if you scan for keys are created at that
particular date
on the key server you'll find a lot of
interesting people that you might know
okay
and
um
what we found is that even to get pgp
installed on various people's machines
was an ordeal and some of the people
basically said this is too complicated
all right
too complicated
so they wanted something simpler
so somebody said well there's off the
record
you know for chat you could do that
okay anyway
that was a big takeaway for me about
this whole per second if you got all
these net graybeards and other people
and they're saying that to improve the
rapsec was just too much of an ordeal
okay
you can see the problem we have going
forward with this internet thing
okay
so unless somebody like commotion
or the free network foundation comes up
with this in a box
but there is no technical solution
because what we found and what schneider
will tell you if you read this stuff
is that when you start doing
peer-to-peer
you've got to have a trust model in
place
you have to trust who you peer with and
how do you establish that trust okay
that's a big problem
and we don't have any real good
solutions now
and just give the example of
after this conference um because
einstein bruce schneier's key he signed
my key and we were right in the same
room and we could check her ids and all
that stuff that's what you're supposed
to do at a key signing party to
authenticate
i get a call from a friend of mine uh
phil carne who's another net guru
and phil says hmm
i see that schneier signed your key
um maybe i ought to sign your key so
let's schedule
a
you know
chat on the phone where we'll
authenticate
okay
and we did
so but you see how does that scale
it doesn't
but how do you
generate trust okay but look at what
happened there schneier signed my key
card says oh okay
i'll sign your key so what happens is
depending you look at people who sign
their key their public key
and then you can make a decision as to
whether or not you trust them
okay and how much trust you want to put
into that relationship it's a start
it's a start it's only six steps
the messages that arrived they didn't
count on us because it didn't arrive
well the question you ask about you know
when you ask the people how many people
use pgp that's not the question that i
ask people
i ask them what percentage of your email
have you encrypted pgp and i generally
found this tends to be less than 10
now it turns out the first person that i
exchanged
pg for my pgp key with
was um let's say a friend of mine at one
of these intelligence agencies and we
were both kind of experimenting but
since that point in time we practically
have never and and this is a guy who
exists in the real
serious crypto world as well too
but i've never found anybody to print
more than 10 of their email
okay i have a story that relates to this
all right
uh
i have this list called dwayne net and
it's sort of like dave farber's ip list
and we sort of bounce stuff between our
two lists
and so i put out a sort of how-to about
how to do encryption
and then farber put it out on his list
and then i got contacted by this woman
who was inside the intelligence
community
okay she had a security clearance and
she was an attorney
you know and she basically went out got
a public key and and she sent me an
encrypted message
and wanted to know if i got it okay and
i said yes
okay then i asked her um
do you know what you just did
okay
and she's because you know this
what with the current rules at the usa
when you encrypt that sets a flag and
that commun that message is saved
forever
okay
and you're in the security community so
you know i don't know what my standing
is with that community but you know i
associate with people like dave farber
who's on the board of eff
okay and i'll have another story about
that in a second so she came back to me
and said well
i'm just a little person you know i i i
don't think i'll you know and i said
really
and we we terminate it i mean it was
like okay that was the last communique i
had with her but it was that sense of
naivete it's like hey i've got nothing
to hide and you know
right
um last june dave was out here for an
eff board meeting and we got together in
san francisco and we're on market street
sitting in a coffee shop just sitting
there taking into sites
and
we started talking about this whole
thing because the stone stuff is
starting to come out and we're like you
know i said dave we're sitting here
generating all this metadata and you run
your list and i run my list and now they
got all this metadata with us you know
sitting right next to each other okay
and
all this is being recorded you know and
you know
and
when you really parse all that
um it's like it's you have to laugh
because it's like what else are you
gonna do
okay now i want to mention something
that i mentioned at this workshop in
september this undisclosed location
there's a television show and i know a
lot of you don't watch television
but it's on cbs it's called person of
interest
okay now
i
didn't know person of interest from
anything and so i had this close friend
whose ex-naval retired ex-naval
intelligence okay he lives in southern
california
so he calls me up and says twain
have you seen person of interest
and i said no no why why why are you
telling me to watch this you know
because he doesn't watch a lot of
television and he says you need to watch
this show
and i said okay you know so then i i i
was in detroit at the time and then i
came here to fremont i'm staying with
some people there
and
one of the first things they said after
i arrived
impromptu was have you seen person of
interest
okay now i was like the ears were perked
up and okay
uh
no okay so i went and got the first
season and blitzed it
and then i called my friend back down in
southern california spook and said okay
i understand
you got this show is done by j.j abrams
fringe lost
this is his version of star trek in
terms of
trying to use
medium to tell a story a morality tale
like roddenberry used to do
okay
because buried in the show because this
is a top 10 show and each one of the
episodes of this show costs 2.5 million
dollars a season is 22 episodes
there's a lot of money
that goes into the show
it's well written it's multi-layered
okay but basically this guy named harold
finch has developed something called the
machine
which is given to the government
and it's basically this ai that's
connected to all this infrastructure
that we got cameras everything okay
and
it gives the government threat
information
but there's a back door that was put in
by uh harold's partner that gives him
social security numbers of threats
that are not threats to national
security
so
finch has put together a team
to go after and try to determine whether
or not those people are
a threat or they need to be helped and
hence person of interest
now
when you watch the show
they have camera views at the machine
you see what the machine seeing and what
the machine does is he draws a rectangle
around people and it has different
colors that indicates the threat level
okay
now there's a lot of easter eggs in this
show so that you'll use the if you're
just a casual viewer you'll see
white rectangles and yellow rectangles
but there are two other kinds of
rectangles
yes
root has her own rectangle
okay
and a
threat
that doesn't know about the machine has
its own rectangle
okay
so for instance it'll be white with red
dots
okay so if you don't know about the
existence of the machine
you have a white rectangle if you know
about the machine it's yellow
okay now
the machine
now this is you could call it science
fiction but the thing is what my friend
was telling me
from naval intelligence was that hey you
know what this thing is pretty much
almost there okay
and
um
there's this the technology that puts
those rectangles around people exists
okay today you can go buy it
so
um
this
to me it's been fascinating that a
top 10 show
with this kind of topic subject matter
is playing in america and people are
lapping it up okay so it's like they
must be getting some aspect of this show
now
recently you know i saw
you have to conclude watching the show
that
our intelligence agencies they have to
build the machine
they just have to they're on a
trajectory to build this machine they're
going to go through hell and high water
to build a machine
and then recently i saw something where
ibm is putting put a billion dollars
forming this watson division
and ibm does a lot of defense work and
then i said
watson plus
the machine
okay
they're gonna do it
if they haven't done already i mean okay
so
watch that show
because like star trek
it speaks to you on many levels
okay
and
also i've used it to get people like for
instance dan gilmore
okay
i went to dan i said uh at this meeting
i said dan you got to watch the show and
dan to his credit
got the whole first season on netflix
watched it all
and he came back to me and says yep
okay
so i can now point other people to this
and if they invest the time to like
watch at least the first season
they can get it so john you got it i
mean
all right
does anybody remembers a movie from many
years ago called enemy of the state
it's very much the same kind of behind
the scenes observation of network
city-wide surveillance systems and so
forth yeah so is madison avenue going to
build it before the
groups
i think they're working on it i think
they have aspects of it okay go to
london or go to england i mean some
people would say england hasn't already
but
they don't
but here's the thing
there's nothing from stopping you to
build your own machine
too
okay you know
what i do with faces yeah space
recognition is very tough it's not
nearly as good as people say that's what
they want you
it turns out that the repo men
nationally are collaborating to build
the
license plate tracking database
story out today in flash uploading
they now claim they're backing away from
that no this is not this is not the
government doing it this is the reaper
dude
a license plate wherever they've seen it
let's see i'd like to go back a bit and
quibble
um sure you
you said that uh
lightspeed communication began uh rather
late
uh
a crude form of it actually goes back
thousands of years it was called smoke
signals
no
that was a limited form of communication
to be sure no but you're into what i was
saying because i said go back to greek
mythology okay and then look for
parallels to what okay turn out right
um and that's great that's a good one
like most
historical overviews
uh you skipped over the first computer
network which was in the 1950s
it
was the sage air defense system
which was a total fraud
i can say that with authority because i
was one of the fraudsters
and it
never worked as an air defense system
never could have worked
but it was kept going for 25 years
for the immense profitability of a
number of contractors and they did that
by classifying its deficiencies secret
and exactly the same thing is going on
today with other contractors
like the
ballistic missile systems
and they're being deployed they don't
work never could work
okay and
you know this this stuff goes on and on
okay well uh
this is the last slide before i open for
questions all right so
the darknet
now again this is a loaded term
i know that
um
so
there's more going on there than you're
aware so let me talk about my experience
with the dark net back about 2000 i was
hired by educause educause is a lobbying
organization for colleges and
universities and there was this whole
peer-to-peer thing going on in the file
sharing in the colleges and universities
they want to get a handle on it they
wanted to find out about the dark net so
they asked me to go out and explore it
and come back and give them a report
so i joined a number of dark net
communities just to get my foot in the
door and figure out what was going on
it was very interesting because um what
i found
was there are these sort of like gated
communities
out there and they basically use the
internet
for tunneling and that they have
tunneling protocols okay so they just
use the
uh
internet to move their packets around
and
uh and they're not all about sharing
files and stuff there's a lot of stuff
going on in the dark net
so uh i was able to get into several
gated communities and um
uh what i found was this thing going on
which is this all for one and one for
all protocol
okay
people bring their machines their
bandwidth storage to the party
and
nobody pays anybody for anything things
just happen there's agreements cut
okay and things
content is shared whatever it's a pretty
dynamic system for instance
i've been part of a system that's sort
of based in the uk
that
you can have act that has essentially
accessible online
pretty much everything that's aired on
radio or television in the uk since
about the 50s
think about that
a library that's pretty big
that you know
rivals the bbc
but it's all done by people and nobody's
paying for it nobody's exchanging you
know and everybody's bringing something
to the table
to me this is remarkable and that's what
i went back and told educause and
i found that
they didn't really want to hear it
because it was a message that they
wanted to float around the beltway
okay
so
what's going on in the in the dark net
is what i think exemplifies the internet
which is innovation without permission
asking permission
okay you just do it
and you're seeing new protocols and
stuff being developed because there's
this sort of arms race with law
enforcement
okay so you've heard of all about the
pirate bay well the pirate base
basically now developed technology so
that you can't find it anymore
okay but it's out there
okay
um and so it's been a forcing function
that i think
uh we sort of need with other second
curve internet efforts
okay
so that concludes my
remarks
and now i open the floor for questions
okay i'll make a couple more remarks
i claim that
there are something like eight key
inventions that made the modern internet
possible
and most of them
were made
altruistically
no patents
completely open
the people who made those inventions
helped others develop them further
and had that not happen but the internet
that we have today would not exist what
we would have is a set of proprietary
networks
uh that don't function at all well don't
talk to each other
and it would be a real mess
unfortunately of course
both commercial entities and governments
are trying to get it under their control
and
if the commercial entities succeed in
destroying
the
uh the openness of the internet as
is currently happening
uh the whole thing is going to go down
the tubes so
we can only hope that
the technology can
keep ahead of
the attempts at getting it under control
well that's
a personal opinion
um just for for for what it's worth
i
in addition to helping create the first
computer network i
helped
design the arpanet
and i noticed you used the start date of
which is what other people claim is the
start of the arpanet
uh it actually did not work then
it actually began
working around 1971
um
and
then
the next step was of course the internet
protocols
uh which you incidentally were developed
here at stanford
by vince surf i i helped him set up that
project
uh in 1973 i think it was
and
sir what's your name
les ernest i
i don't
i'm
finally getting around to writing up
some of this history i haven't published
it yet i know who you
course 69 was the the first piece of
what looked like a communication well
there was an electrical there was an
electrical connection yes and that was
that was not a frog but i don't call
that a i don't call that a network no
that was not a network that was a
point-to-point communication yeah but it
was 69 very very much like telegraph
yeah
well anyway yeah let's actually just let
you know i mean he actually had some of
this stuff and he deliberately skipped
over the 69 to 95 period he has hit a
slide
you missed that because i saw when you
walked in
so no it's okay i mean i better that was
a bleak reference to esl too
i missed that
esl the you know the labs and the
trailers
the internet was actually developed
buildings that have been torn down
replaced and those buildings been torn
down
which is why the plaque is now in a
building that
had nothing to do with the internet
altruistic inventions and open software
played a major role in all of this
and
it would not be what it is today
if it had all been developed
under the capitalistic
system so
i think it's interesting that you
pointed out the
person of interest because a lot of is
based around the idea that these systems
have back doors
this is something there's another
reference for that which is william
gibson's spook country which is pointing
out that if you build the kind of
surveillance system that there is in
london
there has to be a way
for the spooks to avoid getting caught
by it
good point so all their rectangles get
erased read the book
what was the name of the book
spoof country by william gibson
any other questions
yes
if you were appointed chairman of the
fcc what would be your priority
i i served on an advisory group that
started in 98 called the technological
advisory council i was on it for eight
years
so i played the great game okay
to
little effect
i would say to be fair during the
clinton administration for two years we
really did stuff and i was really proud
of being on the attack
and then the bush administration came in
and then things changed okay
um several years ago i was actually uh
asked to interview for the
dave farber used to be the chief
technologist so
uh
he was instrumental in getting me put up
to be
recommended to be the chief technologist
okay
under janikowski yeah actually it wasn't
just bush it was also when ronald reagan
came in the office too because
the guys at park had
xerox machines at the white house
and then when the republicans came in
they said what's this stuff really do
with it
that didn't know concept
so um so i would say the technical
people put me up as the lead candidate
for that position and then i had to go
interview with jenikowski's staff on the
eighth floor there and i didn't pass
muster because i told the truth
as i see it
so i didn't get the job
so
uh but to answer your question um
if i was uh
what you will call it uh
the guy that's wheeler
um
i would start by reorganizing the fcc
from the current bureau system it's
inappropriate for the 21st century where
we are now okay
you know
uh it's a relic of the past and
if i did that it would show the beltway
i meant business about trying to move us
into a more measured future
okay
and i would also
elevate the technical part of the
commission
office of engineering and technology is
just that it's a oh it's an office
so it's at a lower pecking layer than
the bureaus
okay
and that's always been the case the
other thing is that the fcc used to have
a tremendous fuel organization
offices all over the country staffed by
there was a guy named phil kane here
that was chief engineer in the san
francisco office who was both a engineer
and an attorney
okay
and reid hunt under the clinton
administration dismantled that entire
organization for political reasons
because
reid didn't want knowledgeable people
out there
second guessing him and saying wait a
minute you can't do that so he got rid
of him
lock stock and barrel
and at that point the fcc lost his
institutional memory and it has never
been the same since
okay
paul baron and i testified
at a non-bond curing spectrum policy
about the time that happened
okay
and after we testified paul turned to me
and said look
i've been doing this for years and
i'm done
okay i mean nothing's going to change
here and
true to his word he was done he never
had
delved into fcpc policy anymore after
that he just went out and did startups
and stuff and did stuff that he could do
real things with
i on the other hand
kept doing that spectrum policy stuff
and whatever and playing the great game
until
martin was chairman
and i gave a talk here in in the
in the valley
and i started out by saying
fcc chairman martin is a waste of space
unfortunately there was a reporter from
communications daily in the audience
communication daily is read by everybody
in the beltway
so a couple days later
headline fcc tac member calls chairman
martin a waste of space
the next week
the attack was disbanded
uh this true true story okay that that
was it was disbanding he could shut it
down so i am credited with
getting the tax shut down
which well i was surprised why i was
offered this c
chief technologist job okay
but
i think there's a story there
to time but
if you tell the truth
that means something even in the beltway
okay
and that people will rally around you
and support you
okay
if you you know have the courage to go
out and speak speak truth that's what i
learned from that experience
okay
well you've got lobbyists and
congressmen well they're all on the take
so what the hell but some people yes
revolutions start with a small number of
times yes you're talking to the
community here so
i would say in closing you're in my last
minute or so
guys
please improve your opsec
okay you know come on
you know you know how to do it and teach
other people to do it okay
you know
yes
from one thing that
you
assumed but
why does grandma want to run a server
and dave weiner actually hadn't
had he had his starting of an argument
he thought everybody should be running
hundreds of servers
and then it turned into blogging but
ignoring that
why does grandma want to run a circle
she wants to outsource everything
and she helps she's called facebook
that's right yeah well
as you know that comes with look at
that comes with
pros and cons
okay yeah
facebook uh on your show
um
person of interest at some point say one
of the people's comments on how hard it
was to get this private information on
people all the things that they were
thinking and so forth
because of the legal issues and mr finch
says yes that's why we invented social
media yeah